I was lost in the drift and really what
I first wanted to do was to take my life
the director is a writer I'll probably
miss things out you master of language
and for nights my night I was a deeply
difficult child my parents sent me to a
psychiatrist when I was 14. I started
doing weird things
I was sent to prison
so the best I could do after a
disastrous childhood I decided was now
concentrate on getting into Cambridge
that changed everything ladies and
gentlemen Stephen Frye
I want to please people and if I don't
please them I get upset I've done it
wrong age 37 you star in a play the play
gets some pretty harsh reviews
I was lost and adrift and really what I
first wanted to do was to take my life
Stephen vanished on Monday leaving a
number of letters for friends that
started my journey into my mental health
when you were 55 it was your third
suicide attempt Fred that's right can
you take me back to that moment
[Music]
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button thank you
and enjoy this episode
[Music]
I'm I'm so fascinated by
um people's foundations their earliest
years their context because it seems so
apparent that that ends up shaping who
we are and who we become and our
orientation in life so as I read through
your story in your earliest years it was
it was an unthinkable roller coaster
ride of twists and turns but what do I
need to know about about Stephen Fry's
earliest years to understand the man
that sat in front of me well
to use the language of the time I was a
disruptive
deeply difficult screwed up child that's
kind of the language they used then and
I think to give myself some I went to
credit I would probably in later years
have been diagnosed as having attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder I was
extremely difficult to keep still and I
found it hard to focus I was I'll say
um at vain as it may sound I think
um intellectually Advanced for my age I
was very quick with language and with
speech
and just seeing things and remembering
things in particular so I never had to
revise and so in that sense I had a lot
of spare time but on the other hand
socially and where it matters to a child
I never fitted in or felt fitted in
because I was bad at all the things that
are valued when you're a child I
couldn't catch a ball you know I sort of
did the the sort of uncoordinated hand
clapping method of trying to catch which
is always mocked and like just as you've
done and the Cry of Uncle would follow
me short for uncoordinated and worse
kind of words we certainly don't use now
to describe it
should we say a dyspraxic figure in
terms of you know physicality I was just
you know I was growing too fast and Too
Tall and very thin hard to imagine now
uh and I wasn't musically very gifted
particularly uh and I couldn't draw so
all I had was my passion for language
and and I loved it and I played with it
and I told stories and I tried to make
myself
less unpopular put it that way by by it
was a boarding school I was sent away at
the age of seven in Britain which is not
a huge country it's about as far as you
can be from home though my parents were
in Norfolk on the east coast and I was
sent to gloucestershire on the west
um uh to a prep school from the age of
as I say seven which to some people
sounds a bit cruel and weird to send a
seven-year-old boy 200 miles from home
and just have them there
but you have to remember two things one
that was what happened as far as I was
concerned my father had gone to a
similar School my mother had bought it
since she was four
um but that was because she was a Jewish
Refugee in in England and her father
wanted to hide her away from the
impending Nazi invasion and so that that
was a particular reason but my brother
had gone at that age and of course by
definition everyone at the school was in
the same boat
so you just thought that's what happened
I mean if you take a child and put them
in a Cupboard between half past two and
three in the afternoon and
um shout at them through the keyhole
every day they'll just think oh that's
what happens you know and then you
welcome them out and give them a big hug
and say that was your cupboard time you
know what I mean anything you do to a
child regularly is the normal World
essentially until they see other
children having a different experience
but so class locked I guess I was
Without Really noticing it grew up in
the countryside in a large house not
Downton Abbey but you know we had
gardeners and people coming into clean
and that sort of thing servants I
suppose staff whatever word you want to
use
um and it was deep in the countryside
and the other boys that I knew very few
girls but I did and it did no girls and
even they went away to school so all the
boys I knew were going away to school
and the parents you met say when are you
going off to prep school then Stephen
okay when I'm seven and they go very
good uh and that was it because I didn't
know any other children I mean that
sounds monstrous but that's just the way
things what are you stuck to your own
um it wasn't outright snobbery or
anything it just was this was the world
into which I was born so you don't
really question it particularly
and through most of my prep school time
age 7 to 13 is a prep school in Britain
I was very disruptive I passed exams
very easily
I tried as hard as I could to get out of
any form of physical activity I gave
myself asthma attacks and all the rest
of it in order to be put off games
because I just hated them particularly
rugby and the muddy cold horrible things
running and the Collision of bodies and
bones and was just so vile
um I wanted to sit and read a book you
know by the side of the field and humor
particularly then as I moved to 13 and
went to the big school you know the
public school as it's known though of
course then anything but public they're
private
um and that that was scary because at
600 boys
um rather than the prep schools 90s so
it's a much less of a little nest and
much more of a oh but I was 13 and so
when you're 13 as you know too well
chemical starts start to boil and bubble
inside you and things begin to happen in
your mind and soul and
um
I was not prepared for the astonishing
cataclysm the catastrophe the Glorious
catastrophe of love it had never
occurred to me that it would it would be
what it was which is silly because we
grow up hearing nothing but love songs
and what did the Beatles do go on about
Love Me Do and please please me and then
money come my love and hold my hand and
everything's a Love Song and suddenly
when you fall in love all those lyrics
make sense and you realize there's
nothing else in the world and nothing
else is even slightly as important and
of course I was in love with another boy
and I was aware that that was probably
not the right thing
and it it threw me out of everything
really I I just stopped being able even
to pretend to be a normal well-behaved
Schoolboy I started doing weird things
like climbing the roofs of all the
buildings the big chapels and churches
and the classrooms and so that was the
first school from which I was expelled
I'm going to compress the story because
it gets kind of goes on and on and on I
was then expelled from another one and
then kind of another one and then I left
and went to London left home went to
London
and the the major problem there was
I was in a pub it was getting a bit
chilly I saw a coach like the look of it
a half inched it stole it and left the
pub and then discovered there was a
wallet in it oh my goodness and two
credit cards
so I went absolutely nuts around Britain
with these credit cards staying in Grand
hotels and buying things and traveling
and so on in those days they didn't even
have magnetic strips on the back of
credit cards for for you know that you
just have to roll them on a piece of
carbon to to take an imprint so there
was it was very easy to use them
fraudulently as long as you looked
vaguely convincing
I I was aware because my father once
lost his Barclay card that it was the
bank that paid not the poor fellow whose
cards I'd stolen so I didn't feel guilty
in that rather pathetic way we do when
we try and square our dishonesty and you
know
um eventually I ended up in Swindon of
all unlikely tons I think I was going to
meet a school friend and the idea was
going to go to the reading Festival
um so
I stayed in the hotel in Swindon and
that's when uh a couple of I got back to
my room having been shopping there were
a couple of men in the room which I
thought was rather weird uh and being
used to hotels by this time I assumed
they were like cleaning or maintenance
people I said no it's all right don't
need anything and then then said my name
only Not My Name the name that was that
the name of the fellow whose credit
cards I had stolen let's say his name is
Mr Smith and I went yes and they said
Wiltshire CID held up there
and suddenly I realized that the jig was
up I was sent to prison uh on remand I
was said to a Young Person's institution
on Rahman while they waited there were
Seven Counties I think that had
paperwork that I'd traveled in with
these cards that had to be caught up
with
um you're 18 uh 17 just turning 18
that's right yeah by this time so it was
interesting because I was reading about
your as I read through those first 18
years of your life I saw someone with
clearly huge intellectual potential but
also which doesn't seem to be very
common with someone who exhibits those
qualities someone who was kind of like
rebelling against Society had this sort
of I think in your own words an
addiction to stealing things
um and is that and I couldn't quite
figure out why but what I'm
understanding now is because it comes
back to that feeling of being an
outsider and kind of rebelling against
the society that you weren't able to fit
into I think that's exactly right and I
I my parents did send me to a
psychiatrist when I was 14 15. he was
odd enough A Member of Parliament under
Junior Health Minister as well as a
psychiatrist
um so a very Grand Harley Street office
you know with one of those enormous
Montblanc fountain pens the size of a
small submarine with which slowly writes
things down and uh he was slightly
annoyed my parents weren't uh in the
Diplomatic service because apparently
the way I I behaved and the things I did
were very typical of people from
unsettled families and you know with
sort of constantly moving and and so on
but he he prescribed me something and
later I found out when I was doing a
documentary about mental health and I
went all the way back to my school and
spoke to my old school Master he had a
copy of a letter from that psychiatrist
in which the psychiatrist had written
bipolar question mark which I knew
nothing about at the time that was when
I was 15. so there was clearly some
mental they recognized there was a
mental Kink if you like a hundred years
ago had been called a moral King
basically they're just saying he's a bad
lot you know but we were on our way to
being more understanding about
children's Behavior but yeah it's that
whole mixture my love of literature and
stories and wanting to be involved in
the in the world of ideas desperately to
learn more and to understand more and to
share ideas
um uh a cheap wish watching Parkinson
every Saturday night to be famous I'm
not sure how that could happen it seemed
absurd and a deep deep like a like hot
lead leaking in the stomach whenever I
contemplated my sexuality this feeling
because all I I read and read and read
around it you know you go to a library
in those days because there was no World
Wide Web so you use what was known as
the bibliography at the at the back of a
book which would recommend other books
that were sources for that book and so
you would build a web of connections of
so I read a biography of Oscar Wilde and
that led me to biographies of other
figures in his Circle and other figures
later and so on and I saw there was this
extraordinary tradition of literary
artistic people
um who were who were Queer as we'd say
now and of course the ones I was reading
about were were born in mostly into an
elite part of the society that allowed
them to go and live in North Africa or
Italy or Greece or somewhere where it
wasn't quite so dark and you know
oppressive uh but the average person you
know who was born queer had a miserable
outcome it was illegal and you the
police would treat you dreadfully and
the newspaper articles and and so I saw
ahead of me a life of Shame and secrecy
and
all abstinence and you know sorrow and
just you know there was no possible way
the world would be open and free for me
it would just be the best I could do
after a disastrous childhood I decided
in prison was now concentrate on getting
into Cambridge become an academic forget
anything about the world because the
world wasn't for me and that would be
enough and it would also repay my
parents for the extraordinary stress and
distress I'd I'd given them and so I uh
when I was put on probation finally at
the end of the prison thing having
served quite a bit in Roman I was just
put on two years probation went home
told my parents I would look after
myself in Target got jobs got myself a
moped went into Norwich did a course and
amazingly got a scholarship to Cambridge
officer yeah so that changed everything
it is the most remarkable
turn I think that I've ever I've ever
seen in someone's life I think I've
never seen someone who has a series of
sort of criminal
um engagements gets expelled from school
multiple times I read at 17 there was
there was a suicide attempt after an
argument with your father that's right
which led you to be in hospital as well
you end up in jail
and then from jail
you go to Cambridge it doesn't seem like
that it doesn't seem normal and while I
was at Cambridge for the first year I
was on probation still Jesus I remember
saying to to one of my uh Tutors or
supervisors I said oh look at the date I
said I'm no longer on probation and he
said you weren't on probation thinking
I'm in some sort of academic probation
you know that I hadn't done good enough
essays that I've been given a warning
that I better work harder he said you're
not on probation I said well actually I
I told her he said what the hell you get
out why didn't you tell us I said well
why didn't you ask me well it never they
never asked so but it is extraordinary
how everything turned because you know
in the first kind of week I met Emma
Thompson who was an undergraduate
reading the same subject English and I
then saw her in a play and I was just
knocked out I couldn't believe it I had
considered maybe I should do some acting
at Cambridge I started doing that and
really enjoyed it but did lots of other
plays as well and I wrote a play called
Latin it was a comedy
and that went to Edinburgh and it won a
prize and and Emma um came to see it and
brought someone along to watch it that
she thought um might enjoy it which and
I didn't remember this experience but
that person was Hugh Laurie and he
apparently came and watched the play and
and said hello briefly
then
at the end of my second year
I was approached by Emma who said I'm
going to come around and introduce you
to Q There you have met him and I said
no I haven't and she said yes you have
um anyway she took me over to his
college and not on the door on the door
opened he was sitting on the bed with a
guitar in his lap and he said hello and
I said hello and his girlfriend was
there making cup of tea and he said I'm
just writing a song and he started to
play a bit of the verse of the song and
I said oh it's fabulous and I sat down
next to him we started to work on on the
lyrics of it I did some ideas and then
we'd built it up into three or four
verses in the courses and the song was
finished and then he picked up piece of
paper we started to write a sketch and
Emma and Katie were just staring at us
and said what's happened we didn't you
know we barely didn't ask each other our
names we just
immediately just fitted I'm sliding my
fingers into each other there to give an
example
um it was I I described it's like
falling in love but in a platonic comedy
love um we just seemed to gel straight
away it was most extraordinary so from
that moment on we started writing stuff
together
um for our show
and I thinking that either I was going
to stay at Cambridge to be an academic
or maybe I was going to go to a drama
school afterwards and join the Royal
Shakespeare society and hold Spears and
Bellow speeches and now there was this
strange possibility of using comedyism
as a a way of going forward and maybe
not staying at Cambridge at all but
trying to you know tread the boards in
an amusing way why acting I I said I sat
here with Maisie Williams who's the the
young Game of Thrones actress indeed I
know yeah yeah and I I find you know and
then I read this book called um the body
holds the score and it talks about
six ways that we can
help our mental health in things like
yoga and all these kinds of things but
one of them is acting and it talks about
the role that you know this kind of
separation from Identity and how that
can be liberating and wonderful and when
I when I heard you describe your first
acting experiences you use words like
Blissful and amazing and as if you'd
found your place in the world it's true
I mean it is also it is the
acknowledgment the the love or the sense
of attention you get from an audience
that you're uh it's not I mean of course
a kind of vanity but it's not that you
want to be praised exactly it's just you
want to experience that moment and keep
experiencing it it's not that oh look
you must write marvelous things about me
or come up after the show and tell me
I'm a genius that's all embarrassing but
but the moment you're on stage and you
feel that people are looking at you and
not admiring you Stephen but that they
are you have won them over they are
following the story of the character you
are and they are
sucked up into it and you've made it
it's a wonderful feeling but something
even more Primal than that because I can
remember when I was very young five
maybe and my brother was seven going to
a pantomime in Norfolk and the usual
thing happened buttons comes out and
goes hello boys and girls who'd like to
come up on stage with me now and sing a
song my brother dived under the seat and
made noises like a piece of dust so that
no one would notice him like most
children he was damned if he was going
to get up and make an exhibition of
himself in public but I stood on my
tiptoes with my arm up so high that I
nearly split the membranes of my
underarm you know me me me
and we both had the same parents we both
had the same DNA more or less not
identical but not identical twins but I
mean really we're pretty similar in
terms of our
birth and and our parentage and and
environmental upbringing and yet
he would rather have cut his arm off and
go on stage and I would cut my arm off
in order to go on stage and that's just
something that was built in and that was
when I was yet too young to be
self-conscious to have if you like those
kind of issues of self-worth and uh
um you know wanting to lose myself
somewhere else it was just a a young
show-offy I want to be up there that's
you know you see a stage you want to be
on it and much of what you say about the
mental health aspect is true but it is
also the case and I'm sure you've
should have heard stories about this
that even when you're in a very
long-running play when you're in the
wings for the first night you know
there's you are trembling you are white
your heart rate is really up and and you
step on stage and you do it but the
weird thing is six months later if it's
a long run you're standing in the wings
you're talking to the stage management
people like that you're going yeah oh
yeah yeah I'll see you after this scene
and you go on doctors have done this
they've wired people up your heart rate
is as high on that night as it would
have been on the first night it's just
you've got used to it
um the comparison and it's not a
comparison of quality or value is with
an RAF pilot
every day that they're they're flying up
like that and and it's they love it they
just made for it I mean it's frightening
and they hate to see their companions
killed and and so on but
the awful thing is when it stops
suddenly the war's over every single day
you were in a Spitfire you were facing
death you were doing such amazing things
and now there's nothing and so many are
in a Long play of course it's nothing
like being in the Air Force it's of no
importance to anybody except other
people but nonetheless it does cause the
similar kind of shakes in your body and
the excitement and then that's the end
of the Run Stop
and it does explain I think a lot of the
substance abuse in the addictions and
the kind of unhappinesses and breakdowns
and short-term marriages and and
relationships that that are also common
in the acting world I mean it may be
true that there is something good for
mental health but I don't think anybody
would say that as a group act as exhibit
mental health of a of a happier and
better kind than other groups of people
um so so you know it's it's a
complicated story really isn't it it's
so interesting that that sort of
anti-climax I think I've referred to
that before is like gold medal
depression we tend to set ourselves
goals if only I could live in that kind
of a village and you know in the south
of England like a quite near a station
and nice little house but not too
expensive and yeah and then you get it
and so yeah you live in the suburbs
hooray
um oh oh maybe that car that that new
one there that Tesla or whatever I'll
get a then I'll be happy you don't
literally say then I'll be happy but
there's a kind of sense of that's all I
really want and each of these goals is
met and it isn't it as the the line of
tier said that's not it that's not it at
all and and we go through life thinking
that's not it that's not it at all there
is something in all of us a whole a need
for connection and love and truth and
and a sense of something beautiful
beyond and we can if you're religious
you call it heaven and if you're a
humanist you you know you call it a full
and achieved life
um of friendship and you know elements
of sacrifice and so on but you know you
know that there's a hope for it but but
if you if you mislabel it and think that
it's connected with money or cars or
mortgages or jobs or status you're never
happy because of your status because of
things you've achieved you happiness
comes from
somewhere else and of course
I've yet to meet anyone who can tell you
where it comes from regularly where it
can be tapped like some resourced Ah
that's where you get your happiness we
know there's fake happiness from a
so a blow of a drug or something like
that and that couldn't be a more fake
happiness
um and there's the happiness of sitting
around a table with friends that's
beautiful fleeting moments with friends
and family where it's all working and
people aren't shouting at each other and
you can just look at each other I I was
at a memorial service and for a very
dear friend the composer Leslie brickers
you know who wrote feeling good and Pure
Imagination for Willy Wonka and
Goldfinger and a lot of great songs he
was an amazing songwriter and and I
remembered I had a this diary entry when
I was just getting to know him with it
there was a party I think it was his
birthday and it was full of people
someone from Super Famous and
extraordinary people but he I remember
just catching sight of him
and thinking he looked so like a Persian
cat just looking from one friend to
another with his huge smile on his face
just being happy to have his friends
around him it's a simple thing and yet
it's the best thing and and we Chase
we Chase things that give us less time
to see our friends we we we chose work
targets and we chose Journeys and
holidays and things with individuals and
so on that but
and I think we grow away from it I think
the older you get
that the less you appreciate friendship
which is really sad when you're in your
20s you tend to do things as a group you
go on holidays as a group because you
haven't yet got married and partnered
often paired off so I don't know if you
agree with me but I do think maybe that
one of the one of the jobs of getting
older well I'm convinced it when the job
is getting older is not to become
nulled you know like a tree when the
tree is Young you can bend it it's you
know a green stick as they call it you
can bend it and shape it and so on and
once it gets old you know and it starts
getting that bark and if you tried to
bend it it would snap
and and we become a bit like that coming
back to the the the first point you said
there about the goals we should be
striving for I found that really
interesting if not if not striving for a
gold medal or this thing or that thing
how does someone you know listening to
this now what kind of goals do you think
would protect them against that gold
medal depression what kind of
orientation
it's an interesting point and of course
I I you know obviously understand that
there are people who need to meet goals
in order to pay debts and you know that
there are certain amounts of money they
have to have to pay for the heating and
their mortgage and all the rest of it
I'm obviously not suggesting that that's
valueless because you need to keep a
roof over your head and everything else
but in terms of one's own personal sense
of fulfillment and self-worth and
achievement
um I'm more and more convinced that it
comes from how you treat people and how
they treat you back and how you how you
would try to be a better person I know
it sounds really silly I'm not a
religious figure at all
um but but I'm very interested in
religions
um and I can understand that in some
cases religions help cement a sense of
community I where I don't like it is
where it's exclusive of course or you
have to buy into a certain set of ideas
and uh so-called truths in order to be
part of that Community but I can
understand how
looking at a wider sense of of life and
it's really about when you're falling
asleep at night and this may just be me
can I fall asleep at night and feel I've
been a reasonably okay person that day
is this someone I have to apologize to
next morning did I was I short and sharp
with someone was I a bit mean was I lazy
did I did I lie and rare because I
wanted my own way there
um and that's not suggesting I'm a saint
and I always manage it to but I do have
a very loud voice in my head
philosophers call it a deontic or
deontological voice this sense of
obligation that is
peculiarity it seems of our species as
far as we know the image I was used
because they look so cheerful an
Amazonian tree frog perched on a branch
with its big grin
isn't thinking oh God I was a terrible
Amazonian tree frog yesterday I really
let myself down I was mean I was unkind
I must try to be a better Amazonian tree
frog what we admire about animals is
they spend a hundred percent of every
day being themselves
and we as humans are fully aware that we
don't we are not fully ourselves we lie
we hide behind we pretend we fail and we
judge ourselves now that peculiarity of
humanity has tried people have tried to
explain it in different ways obviously
the Genesis myth is that it would be at
a fruit it gave us the knowledge of Good
and Evil and the sense of Shame of our
physical selves or all those things that
separate us from animals because humans
since we were cognitively conscious
have been aware that we're animals
because we can see that we defecate and
eat and sleep and mate just like other
animals and sometimes very quite close
to the other animals if we depending
what part of the world we live
but we can also see that we have these
other things that animals don't who gave
them to us where did they come from what
do they mean and how do we live up to
them are they a curse or a blessing do
they make us many gods or do they make
us the playthings of God's a cruel kind
of you know little as flies to wanton
boys to the gods are we they kill us for
their Sport AS Webster put it and you
know so and and there's that's those
oldest questions still
still really
obsesses particularly now of course
because
in the age of AI we're able to be Gods
ourselves we we are making sentient
beings and we will have to decide
whether like the Greek gods we give them
fire or deny them fire and
um maybe they'll kill us but will they
have what we have this sense of I try to
be good
I mean you try to be good didn't you try
my best yeah that's yeah you failed it's
right and and we all like that but we
don't pay much attention to that and yet
it's the most extraordinary thing about
us
it really is and and
um as I say I'm you know I'm not in my
room I'm not a model of moral probity
and uh um rectitude of any kind but I do
have a that loud voice and I've always
had it and when I was a when my
grandfather died
and this is very
but and I first learned to play with
myself I was terrified that he was
watching me because he died and I
thought I can't do this because my
granddad is watching me and it's just
awful and in a sense that in there you
have it in one image that's what
Humanity's been cursed with since our
birth the big daddy in the sky is
watching you and is it's making you
self-conscious and you're holding back
from your true nature because oh I can't
do that in front of God you know and
um somehow we have to square that and
give ourselves permission to be who we
were born to be and allow ourselves to
live the full lives that we feel that
we're on a journey to but accept also
that we will feel that we let ourselves
down and that we're guilty of this and
guilty of that it's a you know very
tempting to be more like you know
someone like Samuel Beckett and the
absurdists and just say there is a
meaning to any of this it's absurd life
is absurd and meaningless and no very
well that in in philosophy there are
very very few professional philosophers
who believe in free will
but we all live as if Freeman exists and
we all have to live as if we are
accountable for our actions otherwise
Society falls apart but if deep down we
know that that really there is no free
will I I mean the most extreme examples
are in a sense the easiest to see it
what a psychopath is is not just a
matter but it's a matter who is cunning
and who plans coldly they're killing
they choose to kill so you may say
they're the most evil kind but no one on
this Earth has ever chosen to be a
psychopath it's a condition you don't
it's like saying oh he's an asthmatic we
must we must we must lock him up well
you know choose to be asthmatic you
don't choose to be Psychopathic the case
is psychopathic you're harming a lot of
people and causing misery so clearly
we've got to find a way of removing them
from from the natural orbit of humanity
but you know it's just I don't know I
don't really know what I'm talking about
but I'm having fun from that point on
that point of the psychopath how how
possible do you think it is to really
change
um
who we are it's a bit of a strange
question but and I'm very cool good
question past the age of you know 18 you
know the the imprints have been made
into our character identity our sense of
being our search for validation as
you've described and I've seen through
your story and mine how possible is it
to change who we are and are we anybody
or are we just a byproduct of our sort
of DNA and our experiences that's such a
good point I mean we are it is in that
sense we are a story and the story is is
um a mixture of of different elements
um and
a story is a myth it's it doesn't happen
you know it's a bit I'm sure you've read
the the no evil Harari yeah that
wonderful chapter where he just sort of
proves that Peugeot doesn't exist it's a
myth you know it has a symbol it has a
people working for it but there is no
such thing as Persia there's a Peugeot
car but that's not Peugeot and and so on
and similarly there is us
um now if I cut my toe off I'm still
Stephen I'm just even I'm missing a toe
if I cut my head off I'm dead so
obviously you know I'm the remains of
Stephen but if uh if I start in start
cutting more and more bits when do I
stop being myself it's it's it's such a
an extraordinary idea we're aware of our
own self and unless we have particular
problems on the neurodiversity scale for
example uh we also fully understand
other people's selves and that they have
a self and that therefore they have
their own will and their own desire and
the child his other appetites would be
similar to ours so you know if we're
both not eaten for a day and someone
brings in a tray and there's a cake on
it we'll look at each other and we'll
know we each want that cake you know
we've projected into the other's mind I
mean in the most simple way theory of
mind kind of shows us that
um but uh what that self is how it can
be in any way
Quantified it can't be removed from the
body as far as we know I mean obviously
there are superstitions and people talk
about astral projection and so on
there's no evidence that's ever been
done
um you can in a metaphysical way reach
yourself
into other people's selves even after
you're dead Shakespeare does that every
day to different people reading his
sonnets or or Jimi Hendrix or John
Lennon does who whoever you know I'm
reached by David Bowie when I turn on
Starman I feel his self is connecting
with me his art yes his poetry his
vision but also the self he talks to you
that's what art does and and and in that
sense you are Immortal indeed that was
Shakespeare's Obsession so long as men
can live and eyes can see so long lives
this and this gives life to thee you
know he was aware that there is there is
a way that we communicate Beyond
language
um the the actual sand in the throat of
of words being said vibrating the ear is
one way for language to get into us the
other a very recent invention only five
thousand years is is reading characters
on a page
and writing them uh but they but the
other way is is more is is harder to
understand isn't it but we do connect
with people who are dead who are away
from us
um whom we remember and
there
self is as real without a body
as the self of someone who has a body
so in that sense there is an immortality
but it's held together by communal
memory and by means of communication
like print and if they die then the
selves of the past die as well didn't
they
since you were a young man at the core
of you what do you think has actually
changed if I went to the very core
review and I could I could see it I
don't know hold it in my hand what would
be different at the very core of you
between the age of you know
20 25 and today let's say
I think I'm much calmer I think I'm more
accepting of things
um
I feel less need
to prove myself it may not sound like
that the way I've been rattling on
um I I of course have found a kind of
permanent love I kind of that's very
ungracious but I got married nearly
eight years ago
um and that that's changed things
between to be married especially talking
about that child early on who knew he
was gay and and saw ahead of him only a
life of Exile and shame the the prospect
that I could ever actually be married
and live happily and and for it to be of
no big deal to anybody I mean there must
be people I suppose in the world who
think it's disgusting but don't you
don't often bump into them
um so that that's made a big difference
and uh I'm
ambitious only
for an ex if there's an exciting project
like this film I told you I'm learning
polish uh at the moment to to to to to
be in a film and I'm very excited and
ambitious about the film not because I
wanted to win Awards and be a huge
success but because I really am I
haven't done anything quite like it for
a very long time and so that's a thrill
um and otherwise I you know
I suppose I just I don't need
I don't need to connect to people in the
way I used to I used to be
slight really shy enough to need cocaine
to stay up at night and to go to parties
there was you know quite a few years of
that 15 years 15 years that you've done
far too much research continue but yeah
and and I mean I look back at it and I
think I cannot believe I'm such an ass
but on the other hand there are
friendships I made that I don't need to
regret and things I discovered and
learned about myself and so on but
mostly of course it was a very very
wrong course fortunately not a fatally
wrong course either in literal terms or
in terms of career but um I realized
that I am a very very quiet domestic
soul I don't like going out I don't like
parties I I said I said to my husband a
couple years ago I said I don't think
I've ever met a person or read about a
person that I hate as much as I hate
parties he said that's a bit strong do
you hate parties more than you hate
Hitler I said well
that was just a sort of weird moment
didn't it I I do go to parties but I
don't
standing up talking to people with a
drink in my hand it's just mind you have
Agony because I tell you another secret
which you may have uncovered but it's an
embarrassing one is that I have a
condition called prosopagnosia it means
face blindness it means I will see you
in the street two days time and I will
blank you because I won't recognize you
I'm afraid and and it's absolutely
heart and gut wrenching because you are
convinced that people think you're
looking down at them and you don't care
about them you haven't bothered to
remember them because they're
unimportant to you and it really isn't
that I remember names all the time most
people the other way around yeah
remember faces but not names but I and
it it is I have a little card in my
wallet that says being a prosopagnosis
society and I give it to people I say oh
God I'm so sorry but look believe me
um you know like so I did an event for
mind last night and there were some
wonderful people in it I was moderating
it the the mental health charity and now
I was thinking in the camera on the way
home I said if I see any one of those
people we had this wonderful
conversation the chances of my
recognizing their faces are so low it's
awful and and you know you teach
yourself various things like the color
of what someone's wearing on a
particular day or if they have a you
know
earring or some sort of jewelry or
something external to the face but it's
a it's a very odd one so that makes
parties even more difficult as you know
Intel are now sponsoring this podcast
and last week I introduced you to Intel
Evo platform the badge of approval for
high spec laptops that pass Intel Zone
strip requirements and enable you to be
more productive on the go as someone who
spends most of their life on the go it's
Intel Eva that really caught my eye when
we were discussing this partnership the
idea that Intel gives your laptop the
seal of approval for you on all things
like all-day battery life fast charging
and high performance makes my life
easier when I'm buying a new laptop
because I know that if it's got that
Intel seal of approval then it's going
to be able to keep up with me they've
basically done all the hard work and
research for you and confirmed it's
going to be able to keep up with your
busy life on the go head to intel.co.uk
EVO to find out more about intelivo
platform also for a limited time you can
currently get 15 off all Intel Evo
devices at johnlewis.com the code is Evo
ceo15 that's
e-v-o-c-e-o15 until December 11th so
head over to John lewis.com to check out
the Intel Evo designs and get your 15
percent off terms and conditions apply
see more details in the description box
age 37 you star in a play which again
called cell mates I believe that's right
um the play gets some pretty harsh
reviews to say to say the least from a
lot of the big newspapers as such
um and that's another real no moment in
your life usually so can you take me
back to that moment yeah it was pretty
Grim I mean I I we're done previews of
it in Guildford and
maybe what Guilford and Richmond I think
before coming into the West End into the
Nell Khan theater as it is now the
Albury as it was I think and I was with
Rick mail whom I loved and sweet funny
man he was brilliant and and Charming is
always the rest of the cast were nice it
was written by Simon gray a British
playwright he also directed it and I was
playing George Blake the
spy the British spy uh who was sent to
Wormwood scrubs and then amazingly
escaped
um
I was never comfortable in the play and
I was beginning to feel lost and adrift
and deeply unhappy and I couldn't
understand why the good play wasn't that
much of a disaster I mean you had good
audiences and they applauded at the end
and some people said yeah I don't think
it's his best play but it's a lot you
know it wasn't an absolute catastrophe
choice at this point because his
important context you're well
established yes yes in your in in
writing in yes things like Blackadder
and jeeps and moisture and Fry and
Laurie had happened and my books had
been selling so I was you know in in the
public eye was well known
um anyway one Saturday there was a
Saturday night uh I guess the Press
night had been on Friday or something
like that so we then had a Saturday
night and then on Sunday there were the
Sunday papers of which I saw some and
some of which were deeply unkind to me
and uh and that that did make a
difference I mean I I've said I didn't
go just because I didn't like the
reviews it wasn't wasn't entirely that
that would have been a bit weak and and
certainly was a weak thing to have done
anyway but uh it was a whole
concatenation of something wrong in my
head I just suddenly saw myself as in
the wrong
Place doing the wrong things and I
wanted to get away from everything I
knew and really what I first wanted to
do was to take my life and I I did run
the car engine in the lookup garage of
the flat where I was in London and then
realized it was a catalytic converter
that he wasn't really going to do much
harm to me and then there was stuff of
it and I was just coughing a bit and um
uh and and that's quite a significant
decision to make following I know I know
I just wanted out really that's it I
just
wherever I was I wanted to be somewhere
else and and if it was nowhere that
would be that would be a first that was
the most perfect place to be I just
didn't see the as anybody listening
who's had the misfortune and the terror
of considering taking their life
suicidal ideation as it's known in the
trade as it were they were probably
concur with me that there comes a moment
where you just start saying to yourself
what's the point it's a strange phrase
because you know
if anyone could say that at any point
but there's some moments when when you
say it it seems so truthful that there's
simply no point in anything around
oneself and that's how it seems
uh anyway so I got in the car and drove
to the South Coast to
Dover I think it was or no folkestone
and got on a uh a ferry to zebruga in in
Belgium and then ended up in Bruges In
Bruges like uh
like Colin Farrell and Brendan and um I
then wandered a little further east into
Holland and then into Germany and
Hanover and Hamburg and you didn't tell
anybody you were no no and this was 93
or so there was no World Wide Web as
such it was just beginning to happen Tim
bernersley in Switzerland was beginning
to develop the the World by way but
there were these things these these
things called commercial online servers
like CompuServe and America Online
rather than direct kind of internet
connections and
I had been connected to those for some
time and not taking my computer with me
I guess so I was in a hotel in Hamburg
and then I've got a message from my
friend Hugh he said oh better
you must come home
um be in touch at least and so I kind of
sent him an email on this computer thing
and
I agreed that the it was nonsense I had
this in my head this idea that I would
go up from Hamburg and Hanover up
schlesville which is the border with
Denmark and go up into Denmark and
somehow in the north of Denmark I would
sit on a rock in a thick white pullover
with a pipe clenched between my teeth
writing impossible poetry and teaching
English to to Danes and be forgotten you
know and just live the rest of my life
to have a total fantasy
um but no you you said come on it's fine
come home we really want to see you
everyone wants to uh and so I I drove
back overnight to to Amsterdam and my
father had got a flight to scrip on we
met in a hotel in in Skipper and um then
go to flight little little airplane back
to to South End what did you say to your
father that day in Amsterdam when you
met him I said you you've spent your
life getting me out of terrible and
embarrassing holes and this is probably
the worst of them and he said no it's
fine it's all okay and he was just
wonderful I watched a news report of
your um absence really yeah I watched it
upstairs before we had this conversation
of the I think it was maybe BBC News or
one of the big stations that reporting
that you would uh you you were basically
missing yeah a big picture of you on the
screen and saying that you would you
know the way that they'd framed
obviously is they said you did this play
they showed some of the headlines some
of the reviews and they said he's
Stephen Fry's vanished oh my god um
everyone was very of course I never saw
any of that I did see a photograph
someone certainly years later of police
on the roof of my house in Norfolk which
was slightly disturbing looking for
signs of me and obviously feeling the
worst oh it was a strange event but in
some ways it was a cleansing or a
necessary step I suppose because as a
result of it I went to see psychiatrists
and started to try and work out why
why my mind was taking me into such
impossible Dark Places or you know when
I had so much to be thankful for I mean
what the hell you know I had enough
money I was well regarded in my
profession
why should I come to such a crisis just
because someone didn't like my
performance in that play is not really
good enough
um and and not that hypersensitive so
and that started
but I suppose we have to call my journey
into my mental health and
um and a few years later I can't
remember when quite a few years later
probably about eight or nine if not ten
years later I made a program at the bbco
two two two uh episodes I think it was
called The Secret Life of the manic
depressive
uh in which I tried to explore this this
peculiarity of this darkness that can
shroud a mind so completely but also
that is part of a of an illness that I
hadn't really understood I'd heard the
phrase manic depression and I'd never
really heard the word manic
um manic depression is is two illnesses
depression which is a dark depressed
lowered as in depressed state and Mania
is is an elevated state of energy and
and full of full of bounce and vigor and
a desire to communicate with people
and depression is the exact opposite you
just want to lie in bed and pull the
duvet over your head and never speak to
anybody whereas when you're in a manic
State you're always on the phone boring
people so there are two poles and hence
it's also known bipolar there's the the
one pole of of of mania hyper Mania and
the other pole of a depressed state
and so I wanted to find out more about
it and that's where I went back to
school and discovered that the
psychiatrist when I was a boy had
written by polar question mark and I
discovered that so many people lived
with this problem and I also discovered
something quite extraordinary because I
asked everyone I spoke to
I did a little button with my finger I
said I'm drawing a button on this table
with my finger if you press this button
you will never get a depressed episode
again one of those awful terrible
depressed episodes but nor will you get
a manic episode one of those heightened
elevated jubilant episodes
um do you want to press the button and
almost none of them wanted to press the
button and and it it reminded me of a
thing that wh Jordan the poet had
written but don't take my Devils away
or my angels will fly away too and and
I don't know whether that's a true thing
but it's a fear that we have inside us
that even an illness like like manic
depression and how serious it can be is
part of us and and gives us a secret
power gives us something extra
um it's dangerous because because it is
I'm highly
the word doctors uses is morbidity in in
other words you know people especially
if it's undiagnosed if you start finding
that you're crashing in moods and
becoming miserable and and everyone's
finding you a pain in the ass or you're
absolutely wild and full of crazy plans
and you know buying things you know
going on shopping sprees or being
sexually exhibitionist or inappropriate
and people find that even more annoying
um and if you don't know that it's
actually an illness then you just mask
it with alcohol and narcotics of one
kind or another and they must get pretty
successfully but they have their own
problems to say the least and people can
then slide down and leave their families
their families can no longer tolerate
their substance abuse for example and
they they end up on the streets and then
there's a lot of Discovery for them to
know that they first have to get off the
substances that that have been masking
the problem and then to face the problem
and and it's a really as we know now a
huge endemic problem it seems in in our
culture and Country amongst young people
it's expressed with a rash of self-harm
that is is just so so upsetting to see
children are hurting themselves and and
if you ask them why they do it it's
what's the same answer is it's to just
to displace the other pain inside them
it's because the pain in there is worse
so you do that to take away from it and
that for a child is is just
heartbreaking to imagine
post-diagnosis of manic depression
what were you advise to do and what did
you do to make
life better with the understanding now
and the awareness that you had this this
condition
well firstly I went on a sort of uh
exploratory journey of of medication
um a psychiatrist tried me on a number
of things sodium valparate which has
since become somewhat of a some of us
have a disgraced pharmaceutical
particularly when when it's been given
to people with um various forms of
epilepsy
um and then lithium and I was on lithium
for quite a number of years and and then
slowly I became aware of
some of the kind of folk wisdom that has
been around in our species for a very
long time but which was initially very
irritating I'll give you an example
um there are certain kinds of people who
if they hear someone's depressed say
well go go walk it off you know just go
for a nice walk and you think hang on
this is an illness just saying go and
walk it off
and yet once you've confronted it and
once you've tried to control it once
you've understood what it is a chronic
condition I.E a bit like asthma or
diabetes something that's with you and
that may not go away and may come back
again and isn't necessarily under your
control you then do discover that there
are
Therapies in life like exercise
gardening making music knitting I mean
it doesn't almost matter what it is it
is like as I say a folk wisdom of taking
yourself out of yourself and also
believing in the future
incredibly important the first thing I
did I think that was a breakthrough for
me was that I lost some weight I mean
I'm always fighting weight but I was
really pretty pretty big back then and I
managed to lose about four stone now
it's not that losing four stone is in
itself a vast achievement but it tells
me that I can control some part of
myself my physical body is not is not a
rogue that will look just do whatever it
wants to do I can say no I'm going to
make you a bit sleeker and if I can do
that with my body maybe I can do things
in my mind maybe I am you know captain
of my soul master of my destiny and all
of that so yes I started walking every
morning uh you know when I was in London
around Regents Park and listened to
audiobooks and just choose all kinds of
books that either I hadn't read for
years or I'd always meant to read you
know whether it was Dostoyevsky or
Agatha Christie it wasn't about high
literature necessarily it was about just
having a story in my head and walking
and walking and looking and saying wow
it's seven miles this morning that's
amazing you feel you're doing something
so it's really been a slow process of
allowing myself I suppose to to
be who I am and not to fight for my
place at the table I suppose I've
accepted that
um through immense Good Fortune I am
where I am I don't need to say yes to
everything that I'm asked to do I don't
owe it to the you know to to myself to
to have to work all the time
um and so I am sometimes capable of
saying looking to myself in the mirror
and saying you
quite happy today aren't you Stephen and
then I'll go no don't say that it's the
worst thing you could say you've got
almost 13 million followers on Twitter
what's your relationship you've been
with social media because you know up
and down I mean Twitter he really is a
cesspool at the best of times negativity
and abuse and trolls so reflecting on
the you know the experience you had when
you were 37 with that critical feedback
I mean Twitter is not not a great place
to be if you want no indeed it isn't I
mean it is supportive too I mean I I
I've learned how to use it in a way that
is not likely ever to upset me anymore
there was a time when I was fully
engaged with it and yeah you call it a
cesspool and and I've used similar
images in the early days it was like a
lovely swimming hole in the in a in a in
a Glade in a lovely wood somewhere where
people of Good Will and from from Iran
would swim about and you'd bump into
them and go Hi how are you and you just
chat and then suddenly you notice result
there's a turd floating on what the
hell's that doing there and then
suddenly there'd be a bit of broken
glass when you put your foot down and or
old rusty pram or something and you
realize that did you become as you say a
kind of cispool and and that's a
terrible shame it's immensely useful to
have that many followers because it
means you know I can satisfy a few
publicity requirements with one stroke
of the pen as it were just by by
tweeting about them and it will reach a
bigger audience than if I spend four
hours doing a profile with the
journalist who always want to get under
my skin and ask annoying questions so
it's a lazy good publicity uh tool
um I'm I'm slightly worried uh that that
I don't know that I may have to leave it
if Elon Musk takes over I'm not really
sure that I want to be involved in his
Twitter it doesn't sound like a nice
happy place
um I mean I've consider I might just
simply stop using it in any other way
except
things for Charities or work that that
you know but rather than engaging in
people I just I'm not sure I want to see
some of the tweets that float up from
the kind of people that musk encourages
I mean that I may be wrong it it and
it's not that I want it to be a
left-wing thing not a right-wing thing I
mean I'm funny
um of course aware that it should
reflect Society uh as much as possible
but uh
um but you know what I wanted to do in
this in sort of ways go on one of those
doesn't Piers Morgan do something is it
GB news he does or one of those things
yes
um and you should I've sort of wanted to
go on now you'll have to hold your ears
now sort of go hello how are you you old
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] great to see you
and him to go true you can't say that oh
I thought this was the home of free
speech isn't it I thought I thought it
was just a [ __ ] home counting Free
Speech but it isn't oh so free speech is
negotiable dude there are bits that you
can't say and bits that you can you know
because that's that's the point I mean
free speech is of course important but
it's not
it's not the end point the end point is
human beings living together in peace
and Harmony and happiness as much as
possible without war and violence and
envy and resentment and bitterness and
or starvation and poverty and all those
sort of things that that's the end point
and it's probable that that endpoint is
better arrived at if we live in a
society where you're free to speak and
share ideas and think freely and you're
not told what to say and so in that
sense free speech is very much one of
the key things on the way to it but for
some people key speech has become the
end point I want to live in a society
where I can say anything it doesn't
matter if people are starving in the gap
between rich and poor is wider than it's
ever been uh the only thing that matters
is I can say what I want well that's
that I just don't think that's what John
Stuart Mill and all the original figures
who wrote on Liberty and Free Speech I
don't think that's quite what they meant
and I didn't think it's what I see as
the the you know the be all and end-all
but
um
so you know I'm worried that
there will be a rise in the kinds of
anti you know kind of racist and
transphobic and indeed anti-feminist on
the other side and all kinds of other
nastiness will prevail and
musk would go yeah that's that's what we
call Free Speech I'm a free speech
absolutist he called himself
it is it I mean it is concerning it is
concerning generally I I've made the
decision that I just don't I don't tweet
so I just post the podcast when it comes
out and that's it yeah because you know
it's a losing battle you referred to
like pieces of [ __ ] floating past in the
in the once lovely Lake and then a piece
of glass I'll end up having an argument
with a piece of [ __ ] and I don't or a
piece of glass and I just don't want to
I I think what what I think of is like
if at school you're a captain of the
chess club and you put the team up on
the notice board and you pin it up on
the notice board and you then go away
what you don't do is put the notice up
and then hide behind a pillar and listen
to how people respond oh I see the CH
once you put that up for he said wanker
isn't he and all that you know I mean
just put your notice up and walk away
yeah yeah and now to the credit you can
have settings where one of the settings
I have on my Twitter feed is that I
can't see any tweets tweets directed at
me from anybody who hasn't got an email
address verified hasn't got a phone
number verified it doesn't have a
profile picture brilliant so I I don't
get many tweets because you know it
filters out a lot of the stuff so my
notifications are pretty nice you know
they're pretty straightforward and it's
because in the past it has been a
distraction I don't want to fall into
holes you know and spend hours of my
life wasted trying to chase down a troll
um exactly with this journey of mental
health I know you're you're the
president of mind I believe which is a
phenomenal charity that everybody
um everybody probably knows for the work
they've done and the important work
they've done over the last decade is
mental health has risen in public sort
of Consciousness
um I one of the things that I think
about a lot is how the battles we fight
for our entire lives there's all
sometimes a frustration around
our inability to cure ourselves of those
things so you know I sit here with
people or I speak to young people and
even in my own life I've come to realize
that a lot of my like real deep battles
maybe they'll never come a day where
they're cured but my traumas these you
know the ways that I react to something
my triggers maybe they'll never be cured
and as I read through your story even up
until
10 years ago I could see that you were
still having moments of
real lows yeah real depressive lows like
you know I listened to I think a podcast
episode you did where you said when you
were 55 it was you I believe your third
suicide attempt yes that's right yeah
you know no I think I mean it is in that
sense what doctors call chronic like
asthma you you can you know have an
inhaler on you and usually be sort of
safe and you know what you're allergic
to what triggers an asthma attack but
you never stop being an asthmatic and
the day could come when you least expect
it when of course it's always the day
you've forgotten your inhaler where
suddenly you just get this enormous
attack and you can barely breathe and it
might have been 10 years since you last
had such one I'm sure anyone listening
who has lived with asthma will know what
I mean and and it's a bit like that with
with you know you you
at your peril do you think you've
conquered it you're living with it and
coping with it and managing it and most
of the time one manages it but sometimes
you
you hear it the the the the you know the
the hoof beats uh back in the in your
brain of of the coming storm and you do
everything you can to
avoid it and tell friends now I mean
that's it's so much easier said than
done I I have a theory I call it my
genital wart theory is we we all say how
important friends are gosh we need
friends friends the people you can say
anything to aren't they but actually
they're not if you had a genital wart
um you wouldn't show it to your best
friend you say oh Tom here have a look
at my blog see you there we go shut up
simony wouldn't show it to your mother
you know it was your sister you know and
that's family but you show it to a
stranger a doctor so can you look at
this and tell me if it's normal or all
right they'll go oh that's fine don't
worry and you feel okay so if that's
true of some little physical part of
yourself it's also true that the mental
part of yourself that although you have
family and friends who are supposed to
be there for you it's actually very
difficult even though you know it's the
right thing to do to share with them
what you're thinking it's very hard
they'd be upset nearly always when you
have a crisis if it gets as far as
suicide obviously even more so but
anyway they said why didn't you come and
tell me they're actually angry with you
you know I'm there for you why didn't
you come well because I was a genital
wart in my mind as it were and you just
feel and you have to try and overcome
that but yes it I have to be aware it
won't necessarily go away it's it's
um
the other thing I often say is it's like
the weather and and and
um the weather is real you know you
can't ever since I'm going out it's not
really snowing and it's not a blizzard
outside I'm going to wear a t-shirt
t-shirt you have to accept that the
weather is real
but you also have to accept that you
didn't cause it I didn't make it snow
it's it and and nor do you have to uh
sort of Welter in the problem of
thinking well that's it it's knowing
that gonna snow for the rest of my life
it's always going to be cold it will
actually pass again nothing to do with
you you can't make it pass and this
those are the storms in your head
the mistake is not to think it's real
I'm just imagining it no it's really
raining in your head it is oh what did I
do to make it do this you didn't make it
right it's not your fault
and oh it'll never go now it will some
will come out you don't know when it's
not under your control those are three
things they're not absolutely hooray but
they're just enough if you cling onto
them to make you realize sort of what's
going on that it's out of your control
that it's real and that it will pass and
what is the minds it talked about the
Hooves of the horse coming is there is
there words associated with with those
moments is it because you said earlier
on about what's the point yeah that is
often the one what is the point and it's
also just a
it's like I mean all of us who had it
and I'm sure many of the people
listening will have different you know
metaphors and comparisons it's it is
like something being sucked out of your
sort of energy sector and that you feel
drained and you're convinced your face
has gone white and sometimes you look in
the mirror and it has gone white there
has been a physical response to it
utterly white and people who love you
and know you well see it in your eyes
straight away so so my husband will say
whoa what's the matter I'll go I don't
know I don't know I'm just going to go
and lie down I just don't know he would
have seen it instantly and I look at
them myself in the mirror and think what
what is he seeing it is a common thing
and I noticed this during the um during
the uh the documentary uh if you take a
magazine and you know cover half your
face and look at your right eye and then
cover the other half and look at your
left eye or even take a photograph in
that way and then look it's amazing how
I I found people with
who've had mental health histories that
have not been happy have them often have
a more extreme difference in their left
and right eye
then if you look at my left and right
eye one is rather cold and calculating
and one is warmer and friendlier
that's usual with people I think I don't
know any empirical science behind it but
I did notice that almost everybody I
interviewed had an extreme version of
that and I don't know what that means or
whether it's anyone's ever ever done any
research onto it but there are you know
there are signs and signals that come
um
uh it's you know like some people get I
get itchy under the chin when I'm going
to have an asthma attack for example
okay unmistakably itchy under the chin
but with
with Mania which is often worse I mean I
interviewed someone who
with Mania you want to concentrate you
want new projects you've got Amazing
Ideas in your head you're risk taking an
entrepreneurial and grandiose
um and and I interviewed someone in
America who who's uh I interviewed the
wife that the the husband sadly did take
his own knife and so I was talking about
life with him and she said it's a
terrible thing to say she said but I was
always happier when he was depressed
than when he was manic when he's
depressed he's just you know lying
curled up in a ball obviously I didn't
realize it was going to take his life to
go that far that
but when someone's manic they are just
out of control they're so embarrassing
they would do some weird things and she
said she said you'll laugh but it was
awful at the time he had a car a nice
car it's like a one of the original
Mustangs or something and he took it
apart piece by piece on a large piece of
cloth in his garage as an American would
say and each piece he you know he put
the pencil or a marker he did a little
Mark for where that piece goes and he
wrote what the name of the piece was so
the whole thing and he started chroming
all the bright worker making it all
perfect and the all the engine parts
were out and then he had a change of
state
uh and it moved away from this
optimistic bright Mania and he just
kicked the cloth and all the pieces and
everything just piled into a heap of
junk and the car couldn't be rescued and
there's a sort of metaphor for something
there I don't know what it is but she
said that you know that that's the
problem but when I've had many I had a
manic episode right in the middle of
someone's Memorial it was quite
extraordinary and and it frightened me
because the power of it was so intense
and I I I ran home
and I called my doctor my psychiatrist
Billy
I said Billy I'm
I have to tell you I've had visions and
I feel the closest I can describe it to
is like Joan of Arc I feel irradiated by
some extraordinary Power and Light it's
the most extraordinary thing and I just
don't know what I'm gonna do he said I'm
coming around
he came around and he said this is very
dangerous day he could see me and I had
I had I'd started cooking and I'd
started um tidying I'd done three
different jobs and the cooking thing I'd
done a plate with quails eggs halved
it's so elegantly around the edge of the
plate it was so beautiful everything's
amazing I said I didn't know why I've
come but I have never been happier and
More in charge of myself he said no you
are not well you are really not well I
can see you it's in your eyes absolutely
kind of off the scale and I want you
just to take this and he gave me some uh
what was it called
um it'll come to me it it and it sort of
calms you down it's an antipsychotic
essential I suppose or an anxiolytic or
something like that that was that was
one of the more extreme manic moments
I'd had and and actually was pretty
frightening because it took me a long
time to get done from it and and I am
the last person in the world to say that
they feel like Joan of Arc you know like
someone who has had some extraordinary
Transcendent you know religious
experience
um but that's that's how I felt you've
you've accomplished so many unbelievable
things in your career in spite of all of
these struggles that we've talked about
um the list is actually too long for me
to to even I wouldn't know where to
start
um as I looked down onto this little
iPad in front of me at all of the
Milestones the the books the the roles
you've played the the scripts you've
written Etc
why why and how why and how you you know
and it's always a difficult question
because it requires us to abandon
humility for a second potentially and
and say something nice about oneself but
why why you
I think the first reason
and it would be the same if you spoke to
a certain kind of musician is because I
write and and I have always written
since I was a little boy I used to write
stories and when I then was at Cambridge
and there was this thing of Comedy it
was natural as with you and on my own to
write monologues and sketches to perform
and because I'd written them I I sort of
wrote them for myself to perform but the
writing was at the bottom of it all
um and then acting jobs on their own
came along which I didn't write or other
people wrote or I could just sort of add
bits of writing to but I was always a
writer and if you look at musicians
the reason we venerate Bowie and Elton
John and you know Leonard Cohen who
everybody they write their music doesn't
matter how fantastic their voices are
yes we love Nat King Cole or someone
who's just a beautiful voice but
the pantheon of great artists are those
who create their own work they write it
they write the songs they last forever
if you write the song Paul McCartney or
whatever you know I mean you should just
think even something like when you see
that postcode Lottery and that who's
that knocking at my door and you think
that's Paul McCartney when he wrote that
cannot have been thinking but he wrote
and every day he writes to this day
because it's that's what he is that
somehow that's the voice in him telling
him that's what real work is is the
writing and the creating and I love
acting and I love presenting and
um reading audio books and things like
that immense fun but the real work is
always
sitting in front of the blinking cursor
and and and and writing things
um and everything else is is gravy and
fantastic gravy at that not because it's
easier and and oh no I'm not sort of
saying uh acting as easy it's just
for some reason in my head you know the
Protestant work ethic the Jewish
ethically what you like is the one that
says you know sitting alone
concentrating until bubbles of blood
full come out of your ears that's work
acting as Shakespeare called it is play
he was a playwright and he called actors
players do you think we're all artists
this is a really good question and I
always used to say no I I was very
friendly in the Heyday well I still am
uh with for example Damien Hurst in in
the 90s though was very much an obituary
as a Groucho club and uh and and and you
know the Tracy Evans and the
um and the Damien Hurst would come in
along with the Oasis and the blurs and
and so on it was very much the the place
where those incredibly energetic and new
kinds of artists were were dissembled
and you know I'd get drunk with uh
Damien a lot
and I would sometimes say I want to be
an artist and he'd say you are an artist
anybody could be an artist I said no
they can't so what do you mean I said
and I would say I'm an I'm an
Entertainer
I'm frankly a bit Bourgeois I want to
please people
and if I don't please them I get upset
I've done it wrong
for for me the aim is to see Delight in
the face but for you it's to make
something that matters to you and if it
disgusts people or horrifies them you
can you're often full of Glee it's not
you deliberately make them to hate it
there are enough people who love it to
make you extremely rich the time he was
only slightly rich but no of course is
worth a huge amount and I said that's
what a real artist is and my other
artist friends not not all from that
same generation Maggie handling was a
wonderful painter uh in suffocum and
she's done my portrait several times
whatever and she's a reality [ __ ]
there's a toughness about her a refusal
to compromise an absolute
what's Central is her and her work and
that's true of artists artists are
bloody minded they bite the hand that
feeds them I'm pretty easy going uh if a
you know a commissioner wants me to do
something I'll ask him how he'd like it
done I'll try and put my my own voice
into it my own tone into it but I don't
have the artistic drive to make it
something out of me there's a fantastic
confidence and supreme
almost contempt for society that artists
have
um and that's why they're so unpopular
with the daily mails in the Bourgeois
people because they don't please they
don't provide what is comfortable or
easy and what people would like or
pretty or no you know it's always oh
doesn't it's disgusting or throwing a
pot of paint into the Public's face that
was said 150 years ago you know it's
always been thus and artists are special
I think
um I mean I like makers or craftsmen
artisans you know that who make
beautiful things whether it's shoes or
you know Tom Daley knitting a nice
pullover whatever it might be is is a
beautiful thing to see but art is to me
at least and it may be a part of the
kind of education I've had and that has
privileged art above all things but art
is special to me and it has a special
place and does special things
um it usually very simple and and that's
the that's the genius of an artist we
die
we the flesh this case we have dies and
rots
and we know this and most people don't
particularly like to be reminded of it
artists find it the most fascinating
thing in the world so even if it's Van
Gogh with showing the petals falling off
the sunflower there's death in there and
as for Francis Bacon and indeed uh Damon
Hurst and and on almost all painters
they paint death they paint the truth
about what we are becoming and painting
is sometimes the last Bastion against
death I'm going to make something
permanent because everything else dies
that's again Shakespeare's sonnets you
know this will last everything else will
die but this poem will stay here I made
something permanent against death Decay
entropy all the horrors of of the
universe the drag is done you know my
nipples are dropping two inches every
year as as gravity takes hold and it
will for all of us and and art keeps
them propped up if you like
I I very much I've been going back and
forward about this point about art
because I've realized as probably as
I've got older that um expression in
some artistic form whether it's knitting
that jumper like Tom Daly does is so
great for our mind absolutely and um you
know you've talked about a few things
there even when you're talking about
social prescribing just some way to
express ourselves through the medium of
music or painting or creation seems to
be it seems to be so human and so
innately um important to to all of us
um
but at the same time I hear what you're
saying regarding artists and their
conviction to create from their own
perspective versus to conform yeah I
guess I guess maybe the difference there
is that's a being a great artist yes I
think it's true yeah there are there are
qualities and degrees Yeah there's a
spectrum of I mean there are people have
tried to Define I mean an artisan a
Craftsman
I couldn't make the same thing again and
again identically and it's genius you
know they're making four chairs each
chair is the same an artist never does
the same thing again they might have a
theme that they do so you know you can
get a lot of artists who you know uh who
who who like to paint a particular
subject
um whether it's bedding field Terriers
and famous and Scottish artists used to
do crazy HSN um
um he liked to do little Bedlington
Terriers and he liked there's usually a
star somewhere but everyone is different
everyone is a is a variation on a theme
whereas an artisan is happy to make
things that are perfect and the same
each time uh a Craftsman and but they're
both good for the mind in fact probably
being a Craftsman is better for the mind
there's I remember Rowan Atkinson said
to me once years ago he's a very wise
man and indeed and thinks a lot very
very very thoughtful and and he said and
I'm sure he wasn't the first to say it
and there are many different name for
this he said but it only ever works on
stage
if you are relaxed
but it only ever works on stage if you
are concentrating
if you concentrate without being relaxed
you're just stiff and you're trying too
hard if you relax without concentrating
you're all over the place but when both
happen at once you are master of time
and space and you are in control you're
concentrating on every detail and every
second of the audience's response and
your timing is perfect and yet you are
relaxed enough to allow them to enjoy it
without feeling any strain
Sportsman call that being in the zone
and it's immensely important to get that
blend and one of the ways to create it
is I think not to do art because that's
just too frightening but to do crafts
and and that can include painting it
could be painting by numbers it can be
just a general sketch where you're not
trying to make it art but once your
tongue is stuck out you know you've got
that concentrated but relaxed on you and
it comes as I say it could be knitting
carpet making it can be anything you
choose but something or a jigsaw even
but something where you've made a change
to what was there before you brought
materials together that weren't there
before and you've done it in a way that
has just given you that you've listened
to the radio or or the television's on
in the corner or you've got a playlist
going and it's it's a it's a magical
thing yeah and and if if anyone's
thinking of how they might do that one
of my favorite films is a film called
Running on empties Sydney lament film
with the River Phoenix and Judd Hirsch
and those others in it and uh it's about
this family that are on the run because
they attacked her
a weapons laboratory during the Vietnam
war and unfortunately there was a
security guard in there who got killed
although they didn't they tried to do it
when it was empty so they've been on the
lamb from the FBI for like 15 20 years
but that's the back story anyway that
means that they they don't have much and
they're constantly having to go on the
move when the FBI might be close and uh
the river affinity's character is a
musical genius as it happens not as
relevant to this story but he meets this
girl and they start to fall for each
other and at one point they're walking
on the beach and he's picking things up
and says oh this might do and she says
what's that
and he says in our family
for Christmas or birthdays we're only
allowed to give something we've found or
made
and I I almost wept at how beautiful an
idea that was I know it's so obvious we
live in a ridiculous crass commercial
world where we score everything by its
monetary value but to say we're only
allowed to give each other things we
found or made and so we'd found this
Stone and this piece of wood or whatever
Driftwood where it was he was going to
make something out of it and his parents
would be thrilled to have it because
you've given them time and concentration
but you've also had the pleasure
yourself of doing the making so maybe
someone listening will say to their
family hey Christmas is coming up we're
only allowed to give each other things
we've found and made and especially at
the time of of of you know financial
crisis who wants to go into this
slightly sick making nonsense of just
going into shops and spending vast sums
of money that you know and shiny things
and when you might just find a piece of
Driftwood or something that looks like a
hedgehog and turn it into a pipe holder
or a soap dish you know that's all I'm
saying it sounds so cheesy no it's
beautiful it's a really really beautiful
idea and it's very much aligned to
to
the relationship I have with my partner
to be honest we you know I'm sure I'm
sure everybody knows I have the means to
buy whatever but indeed I can't think of
a recent Valentine's Day birthday just
had my birthday where anything has
exceeded the 100 pounds because it's all
like scrapbooks and really sentimental
personal stuff and thankfully I'm with
someone who wants that and would
actually be probably disgusted if I got
them a shiny thing I generally I've said
this before my partner would be
genuinely disgusted if I got a shiny
thing or like a designer thing like the
look I would get you know so I I it
here's a question if you if you're if
the good life in your own subjective
definition of whatever that means if the
good life your best life was a I've
asked the question but I'm going to ask
a variation of it to you was a recipe
constituting of a bunch of different
ingredients what do you think you need
or is missing from that list of
ingredients for you to have
the dish of a good life
wow
that's an amazing thought I mean there
is a part of me that obviously feels I
say obviously that feels in another
world if I'd time things right
I might have had children and and that's
an experience that enormous number of my
fellow humans
undergo and it clearly gives pleasure I
have many God children now
nieces and nephews and great nieces and
great nephews
um and but I'll never experience the the
a child growing up and and and and that
I mean it's
slight sadness it's um it allows me
fantastic
um ironic sarcastic in fact
conversations with people sometimes
where song has always nonsense about
global warming
you know and I'll go no I'm with you I
don't have children either so I don't
care what happens to the world and
they'll go well no I've got kids I said
oh do you hate them then you hate your
children so you don't want them to have
a nice world oh well I don't know I mean
yeah that's fine and they'll go oh look
don't beat you and I get well
silly of me but but it does um yeah I
mean that's probably the biggest hole in
my in my life experience I've been
fortunate enough to have done so many
things and to experience so much and met
so many people I've been thrilled to
meet and had opportunities that are just
unbelievable really and of course I've
had opportunities I suppose to have had
children I mean you know I could have
sorted something out I could have and
you know Elliot and I could you know we
talked about it a bit but we never
we never talked about to the extent of
right so we're going to a clinic
tomorrow to talk this through to some
expert you know we never quite got that
far it was always just yeah it would be
nice wouldn't it
um and uh so that's probably the I mean
otherwise of course there are there are
regrets in life because
um as you get I'm now from the 25th of
August nearly your birthday almonds I
was my birth 24th of August so from that
day onwards I was closer to 70 than 60
which was my 65th birthday on the 24th
of August so as you move towards uh uh
The Seer the yellow leaf as Shakespeare
put it oh
Joe yes sorry I'm still at the um oh God
am I late oh [ __ ] I am yes you're quite
right
the driver is worried about getting me
back in time I understand
thank you darling bless you we're having
such a good time I had no idea how the
time was passing
please apologize for me interrupting I
know I know you yeah
you bet I'd really appreciate it thanks
and I'll I'll text them and I'm in the
cab on the way there gosh I'm sorry no
worries at all yeah listen Stephen thank
you thank you so much for your your time
we do have a quick closing tradition
just where the last guest asks a
question for the next guest that's right
so I'll just rattle this one off to you
um and I absolutely can't read their
writing what is it that motivated you
once you
do you have any idea we already have it
ah what is it that motivates what is it
that motivated you once you already had
it
oh do you mean once you've reached a
goal why do you keep at it you got to
the point in your life where you would
achieve so much most people would be
satisfied with retirement and wrapping
it all in what then became your
motivation in your life does the
honestly pleasure the fact that I still
enjoyed it so much that when I met new
people who wanted me to do a new thing
like this this dinosaur
um program I'm doing dinos yeah uh
living you know doing this new
technology being with the Dinosaurs so
exciting it was just a whole new thing
for me and and I'd never done anything
like it and so I just said yes and even
though it meant like am I going to get
it how am I going to get a week to be in
that studio and do this and enough stuff
and prepare for it and so on it turned
out to be a wonderful program and a
unique kind of Technology demonstrating
these dinos so so that is an example
it's just and similarly doing this Apple
TV show which I'm doing now in America
called The Morning Show which is good
fun and
just occasionally it's it's the thrill
of the variation you know so it's the
variation between doing a documentary
and then suddenly having to spend four
or five months just working on a book
and then uh then doing some [ __ ] piece
of uh uh TV or film with big stars in it
uh feeling like oh I'm in Hollywood you
know it's not that I'm calling the
morning shows like because that's the
least slushy thing I've ever done I've
actually had the privilege of seeing all
of the above other than your upcoming
movie which which hasn't been shot yet
but when I saw dinosaurs it was um it
brought me right back to my childhood
and watching Jurassic Park with ore and
as if I was stepping back in time to a
place in in our history thank you so
much for your time Steve and I really
appreciate it you're someone that's a
real pleasure and do I have to leave a
question for your next if you could that
would be amazing going to give you the
book that I ever see you thank you
Stephen
quick word from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better
as some of you may know by now Blue
Jeans by Verizon offers seamless high
quality video conferencing but the
reason why I use blue jeans versus other
video conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events for many years
people have been asking for a coffee
flavored heel and quite recently he'll
release the iced coffee caramel flavor
of their
um ready to drink heels and I've just
become hooked on it over the last couple
of weeks I've been on a really
interesting Journey with huel which I've
described and talked about a little bit
on this podcast I started with the berry
ready to drinks then I moved over to the
protein salted caramel because it's 100
calories and it gives you all of your
essential vitamins and minerals but also
gives you the 20 odd grams of protein
you need and now I'm balanced between
them both I drink mostly the banana
flavor ready to drink I've got really
into the iced coffee caramel flavor of
fuels ready to drink and now I'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors that the caramel flavor is
amazing the new banana flavor as well is
amazing and obviously as I said the iced
coffee caramel flavor has been a real
Smash Hit so check it out let me know
what you think on social media I see all
of your tags and Instagram posts and
tweets about huel
[Music]
thank you